all right so if you're a cs go fan and
you saw last week's announcement
then uh holy [ __ ]
tom cruise mr consistent the face of
hashtag
to the stars himself the most patient
the most precise and most unreasonably
pretty opera in the entire world device
has joined ninjas in pajamas
we knew something was going to change
with astralis
but this
surprise surprise it's that time again
where i tell you to like the video
subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications so the next
time i put out a cs go down at me
which thanks to you guys have been
killing it lately
you get to watch it straight away okay
so as they say in hollywood
let's cut to the chase last week it was
announced that astralis
star fragger nikolai device reits
had left the organization to become a
nightwear donning ninja
needless to say this is a very big deal
like not just by cs standards
by esports standards now if you somehow
have no idea who
devices well get your [ __ ] head out
of your ass
like even giving you the tldr feels
ridiculous a
four-time major winner 11 time
inhabitant of the hltv
top 20 and 18 time mvp recipient
device is not just the most consistent
opera
ever or the star player of the greatest
roster that the game has ever known
but pretty much the best cs go
competitor of all time
flashed he's gonna get that shot and
that has to feel a little bit going out
middle of the air
to take down alex and now they're
pushing oh he's gonna be kidding me he
takes
every single one from nothing
to the awps like
don't get me wrong mechanically simple
is the de facto filthiest fragger ever
to touch cs go with
zywoo hot on his trail but in terms of
results
accolades and well pretty much every
other metric you can imagine
device takes the cake it's not even
close so if astralis were so great then
why'd he leave well it's no secret that
since the start of kovid
online play has engendered quite a few
hiccups for astralis
while other up-and-coming lineups were
using the so-called
online era as an opportunity to level
the playing field and
ultimately excel astralis saw it as an
opportunity to
i won't say sit back and relax but let's
say
recover after nearly two years of
unprecedented dominance
with two of their core members taking
elongated breaks on account of burnout
astralis decided to start signing young
unproven talent
nurturing them in an academy type
infrastructure while getting serious
about the possibility of putting
together a 10-man roster
and as you can imagine they didn't do
that good
that said as astralis main roster began
to gradually return
their results definitely picked up they
won pro-league season 12
dreamhack masters winter and the iem
global challenge
the issue is that pretty much as soon as
2021 was underway
they fell off pretty hard following a
second place finish at the blast premier
global final
astralis fell into a slump of frankly
awful placings that sent the
counter-strike community for a bit of a
loop
things got especially spicy when device
hinted in an
interview earlier this month that a
change might be in order
the plot thickened when simple leaked on
stream that he'd screamed astralis
seen their roster change and assured
everyone that while he couldn't say
anything
it would shock us all
[Music]
and then about 24 hours later simple
revealed who the missing player was
and it was the last dude that anyone
expected i didn't see device
playing at all like
i never seen it before and for team who
won four majors
the question of course was where could
he be going
and then we found out and [ __ ] ourselves
i sleep in one
[ __ ] time bro i didn't take the day
off i still planned on streaming and
[ __ ] device leaves astralis to nip
in this economy okay so why would device
leave behind
the coach who helped mold him the two
teammates with whom he'd been playing
for like
almost a decade and the organization
that he'd helped
found well part of it was logistical
device's partner is swedish and he's
actually been living in sweden for quite
some time
and according to him it's caused some
undue stress from time to time
there's been a lot of i would say not
stress but there's a lot of time that
goes into going back and forth between
denmark and sweden
and as i've touched upon a little bit i
think that
the energy that that takes is just
something that i could put elsewhere
into becoming a better player
the other reason of course was
performative
astralis system just wasn't firing on
all cylinders anymore so device decided
to start over somewhere else
i just want to learn how you guys do
things and do it your way
and then adapt in that way so just so
you know that i don't want to
come in and change stuff up just really
really impressed with the setup honestly
i think
at least from where i come you are maybe
five steps ahead
i mean how we practice prepare also i
will say
props to astralis for how they handle
the move from a social media perspective
in addition to kicking off a
lovely little dear device hashtag they
put out a truly
awesome tribute video that paid real
respect to device's
indescribable importance to astralis
they need to find a way to get these
kills and get on that ball very quickly
and now it's all cool
as smooya was apt to observe it's
actually
super rare to see orgs dish out actual
heartfelt thanks to a player who leaves
them in the lurch
device was central to astralis becoming
in the immortal words of sadokist
the greatest of all [ __ ] time and
they sent him off
beautifully certainly ringing for a
travis right here one versus four
and he's gonna get a head shot
[Applause]
no way
[Music]
now apparently device had his eyes on
ninjas and pajamas from the get-go
part of this was likely to do with the
logistical reasons mentioned earlier
since ninjas in pajamas is pretty much
the most legendary swedish organ esports
the other part of it was probably the
fact that
nipper kind of nasty with it i don't
even think they can get here this either
works but they're never gonna get close
dupreeh
for the one kill ctrl lining them up a
break triple oh
and they all line up for him a quad kill
after offering
heartfelt goodbyes to get right and
forest in 2019 and 2020 respectively
nip entered a rebuilding state of sorts
where they picked up a bunch of youngins
who
over time injected new life into this
once
dominant org who let's not kid ourselves
had really fallen off in fact just weeks
before the device pickup they finished
top four in esl pro league season 13
and were looking like they might once
again become a household name
and now that they have the most
consistent opera alive in their back
lines
they're primed to do just that as for
who deva replaced
it was knock who despite being
understandably frustrated
couldn't really hold it against nip for
subbing him out for
one of the best operas on the planet i'm
doing nothing
i'm not practicing i'm just chilling on
the bench and looking for a new team
i respect the nip's decision and i don't
and i would like i didn't say i would do
the same you know it's not the everyday
devices
available to pick up devices better yeah
as for the transfer itself
devas buyout is rumored to have come in
at a
whopping million dollars and from the
sound of things
astralis are probably pretty happy with
that since according to mira's recent
hltv editorial
their stock price lowered by six percent
on the day of the announcement
and that's after they already reported
losses of 8.5
million dollars at the end of 2020. now
in terms of who astralis will get to
replace him
it's really hard to say now for those
who aren't intimately familiar with cs
device is a
very idiosyncratic offer like a unicorn
truly one of a kind
why because he's an absurdly defensive
aimbot who's perfected this signature
ultra passive playstyle and because of
that
he's virtually impossible to replace now
that's not to say that astralis couldn't
change things up and sign some
other type of world class offer but
there is literally
no one who can stand in as a one-to-one
replacement for a device
astralis could sign simple or zywoo
and they still would not be able to fill
that void since astralis are seemingly
only interested in signing danes it's
likely that they double back for s
attack since they had great success with
him before
it's also possible that they go for a
danish up-and-comer like yugi or acor
but
needless to say none of those feel even
remotely capable of replacing
device the most logical pickup would
probably be cadian the thing is cadian's
already kicking ass
taking names and vying for the top spot
in the world over on heroic
crazy as it sounds canadian has no
reason to go to astralis
and as mira aptly pointed out elsewhere
in his article
there are other things to consider zipix
has not been the minister of
anything all year magisk is a far cry
from the top player in the world he was
back in 2019
and glaive has a little big brained baby
on the way
i don't know what the future holds for
astralis but i'll be honest
it's not looking especially illustrious
my hope is that they start looking
abroad maybe pick up
kenny s pogchamp smooya
i emoji my boy guardian look a guy can
[ __ ] dream okay
as for nip who's to say that dishing out
big bucks for big daddy devin doesn't
rekindle some of that
good old nip magic i for one
cannot wait to find out the man is
literally the unsung goat one day we
have to do a video about this about this
phenomenon that like the guy is somehow
literally obviously the greatest player
to ever touch cs go
but like simple and zyewu just literally
like oh you no scope two dudes
that's akin to winning four majors like
and i'm the biggest simple fanboy alive
and like even i can admit that like it's
it's just
it's just not fair like device got dealt
it gets dealt a bad hand like
this guy has earned it like what the
[ __ ] else does he have to do
right like